it's extraordinary meeting of council
i will now ask the reverend nick rowan
to lead us in prayers
reverse from isaiah 56 this evening's
reading for the church
this is what the lord says maintain
justice and do what is right
for my salvation is close at hand and my
righteousness will soon be revealed
blessed is the one who does this the
person who holds it fast
and keeps their hand from doing any evil
let us pray
father god in this week of holocaust
memorial day will lament the loss of six
million jews killed in the holocaust
and millions of other victims of other
genocides
may our minds be clear and attentive to
their memory and our hearts be moved to
bear witness to their lives
today help us to remember and recognize
the sanctity of each human life
that all people are made in your image
and today help each of us to maintain
justice
and do what is right
and almighty god from whom comes every
good and perfect gift we pray this
meeting will be conducted in the spirit
of justice and truth and wisdom and
charity
we pray that mindful of their
responsibility and the needs of those
they serve
each counsellor and officer may use
their influence in this meeting to
promote the building up a community and
neighborhood
help them to seek the way of love and
peace
through him is who is the prince of
peace our savior
jesus christ
amen
thank you thank you nick for business
i know how busy you are and i just thank
you for
your understanding that you have to
leave us now
members please be seated
good evening
members
when i invite you to speak please wait
until there is a microphone in front of
you
before speaking as microphones are
needed for the hearing loop and for the
audio recording
please use the antibacterial wipes if
you do touch the microphone
members voting will be done on a show of
hands in line with the constitution
i will ask for a show of hands
for
then against
recommendations and then for abstaining
given the size of the room
and the numbers of us present
can i please ask that you put your hand
up clearly
high in the air so that it can be easily
seen by all of the all and leave it up
until i ask you to lower it
members
councillor steptoe has had to give his
apologies for this meeting for personal
reasons
i would therefore like to move a motion
that counselor robin dre be vice
chairman for the duration of this
meeting
do i have a seconder
thank you council lawton
we will now vote those in favor
that is unanimous thank you
that motion is carried
cancel the dry would you like to come
and sit
here
agenda item one is apologies for absence
apologies have been received from
councillor lumley
councillor lowman
councillor mrs mason
councillor pavlin
and councillor steptoe are there any
more apologies
okay thank you
moving on to agenda item two
declarations of interest are there any
declines declarations of interest
members
there are none okay thank you
agenda item 3
report from the review committee to
council
pre-scrutiny of proposed report to the
council
re-strategic partnership with brentwood
borough council
members
we have councillor chris casa
cossack and councillor steve summers and
ian winslet strategic directors in
attendance from brentwood borough
council
for this item and the next item of
business
welcome
my apologies also i need to include
councillor maria pearson
okay
i'll just re-read that just so that it's
clear
councillor chris cossack and councillor
maria pearson
also are mr steve summers and ian
winslet they are the strategic directors
in attendance from brentwood borough
council
i will now invite councillor stuart
wilson
chairman of the review
to introduce the report
thank you madam chair um at a meeting on
the 13th of january 2022 the review
committee conducted a pre-scrutiny of
the
proposal for a strategic partnership
with brentford borough council
and this was the first time that
our review committee had conducted a
pre-scrutiny review
present at the meeting for presentations
were councillor simon wooden and
councillor chris hossack
who presented two committee members and
also answered our questions during the
debate as well
at the meeting the review committee made
a number of additional recommendations
on the proposed strategic partnership
and i'd like to read those out verbatim
just to make sure that people are clear
what they were
the first recommendation was that the
section 113 agreement make provision for
robust exit arrangements
and a member-led conflict resolution
process
the second recommendation was that the
section 113 agreement comes to the
review committee for scrutiny before it
is executed
the third recommendation was that
feedback from residents
should be received as the impact of the
partnership on services is regularly
sought and reported upon
and our final recommendation was that
there be an early review of technology
in the phase two of the transformation
program to identify both threats and or
opportunities
at the meeting there was detailed debate
of the strategic partnership proposals
and there was clarity sought around
the heads of terms and memorandum of
understanding
it was noted that the cost of the
partnership would be born equally by
both councils with a sum of three
hundred thousand pounds being
contributed by each council
uh going forward savings would be shared
between the two councils with the
starting point for discussions being 50
50.
going forward we expect there to be
further scrutiny so as the program is
executed we would expect to see
various work packages coming back to the
review committee for scrutiny
so the conclusion was that the review
committee unanimously supported the
proposal set out in appendix one of
those and those proposals together with
the additional recommendations from the
committee which are set out in the final
report of this meeting and our agenda
item form
thank you councillor wilson
members does anyone have any questions
no okay
thank you for
councillor wilson and the review
committee members for scrutinizing the
report and making recommendations which
i believe have been incorporated into
the next agenda item
agenda item 4 strategic partnership with
brentwood borough council
before i asked the leader of the council
to introduce the report i would remind
you members that there is one exempt
appendix to the report
if at any time during the debate you
need to make reference to the content of
this
exempt appendix or ask a question
relating to it
can i ask you to raise your hand and let
me know so that a procedural motion can
be moved to exclude the press
and public and office officers
from the meeting
i would remind you
all that there has been a number of
opportunities for such questions given
that there has been a full debate of the
proposals at the review committee on the
13th of january
i will now ask the leader of the council
to introduce the report please
thank you madam chairman
it's a microphone picking me up from
there
good
i'm delighted to present the uh report
uh to members this evening um relating
to the strategic partnership of
brentwood borough council and rochford
district council
before i move into the substance of my
report
what i would just like to mention on
page
4.3
3.3
that of course should indent one of the
recommendations and be d so there's a
formatting so so that we're quite clear
on the recommendations from the
review committee
um
first in particular
i would like to
thank councillor stuart wilson
as chairman of the review committee here
in rochford together with councillor
charles nolan as chairman of the
brentwood audit and scrutiny committee
for their intelligent pre-scrutiny of
the proposed arrangements and their
respective committees constructive
recommendations which are reflected in
the report
forgive me brentwood but particularly i
would like to commend
councillor stewart wilson for the first
review
following the review of review
because actually
whilst i was
a little doubtful as to the
effectiveness of review uh before the
review of review uh if ever there was an
example of a good meeting it was chaired
um by councillor wilson uh ably assisted
with councillor macpherson and members
and i thought you were absolutely
brilliant with the way that you
interrogated
me uh councillor hossack leader of
brentwood
and truly got down to the depths of what
scrutiny is all about so
thank you very much indeed council
wilson because i know you played a large
part in that
members you will be familiar with the
handbook which has been
circulated um and i'm more than happy to
ask officers to append that to the
minutes tonight
by way of refreshment refresher
but i will just go to a few points
because i think it's worth
covering why rockford and brentwood
both are in south essex
both have similar size budgets
there is no administrative boundary uh
joining us to brentwood
in terms of tears of local government we
are both district councils albeit that
brentwood is a borough we're a district
but in governance terms we're identical
and both have a mixed
economic
socio
or i beg your pardon both have a mixed
economy of in-sourced and outsourced
services
and both authorities
have similar socio-economic makeup and
economics
and that i guess is really what brought
us into looking at this partnership
so in terms of the vision
the council's aspire for the partnership
to meet
these following outcomes
an enduring partnership between two
sovereign councils
with a unified officer team that
delivers high quality outcomes for our
communities operating on one culture
ethos
a partnership with greater combined
capacity to manage change and strive for
continuous improvement
a partnership that retains local
identity for our residents and has the
scale to make tangible investments and
improvements for the well-being of our
communities
a well-resourced and fully integrated
modern council officer modern council
officer team delivering for both
councils with built-in resilience
focused on improving frontline services
and effective back office functions
a people first partnership recognizing
that its strength comes from the talents
our people bring through a depth of
skills and experience developed further
through collaboration and creativity
an equitable partnership that brings
financial sustainability and
organizational resilience to both
councils whilst equitably balancing risk
so as i just
said
in summary both councils have similar
size
in terms of democratics and scale
and see the creation of a strategic
partnership within south essex as a
positive position for the future of
brentwood borough council and rochford
district council
the partnership will have no impact on
the independence of both councils and
their own sovereignty our most important
point
this partnership can never become one as
both councils do not border each other
so this is a truly strategic partnership
and we can never be a merger
when it comes to decision making all
decisions for brentwood will be made by
brentwood borough council and all
decisions for rochford will be made by
rochford district council
working closer together offers both
councils increased capacity and
resilience together with a greater
financial stability
we are starting with the sharing of a
joint chief executive which offers both
councils an immediate saving and assists
in the creation of this strong strategic
partnership between our two councils
together we will innovate further and be
stronger while retaining and attracting
the most talented employees
offering them positive futures
and career development opportunities
in a world where we need to do more with
much less a strategic partnership can
make us more efficient and strengthen
our position when working with
stakeholders
it will also increase our ability to
take advantage of commercial
opportunities to deliver better value
for our residents
we want to strengthen our leadership of
place we are committed to building
stronger and more prosperous local
communities
sorry i beg your pardon local economies
within south essex with quality jobs and
sustainable homes
whilst ensuring those that need us most
are not forgotten
our residents and our businesses expect
their local councils to work hard to
maximize local quality of life for
everyone our joint aim is to work
together with the ambition and resources
to make both our areas some of the best
places to live work and visit in the
country
this strategic partnership can deliver
on that
promise madam chairman i'm very pleased
to propose all the recommendations set
out at 9.1 and i'm very happy to read
them out or leave it to you should you
wish to read them out instead thank you
madame thank you councillor
do you have a second
counsellor
mrs rowe
i'm happy to second that
thank you
members may remind you that the normal
rules of debate apply and that no member
should speak for longer than five
minutes
and should not repeat anything
previously said all those those in all
those indicating to speak will be given
an opportunity to speak once
i will be inviting you to speak in the
order in which you raise your hands
but members please be aware that we have
an exempt appendix to the report
can i please ask you now raise your
hands if you wish to ask a specific
question on this exempt document
or to make a specific reference to the
content of it
okay we can move on from there
okay
okay councillor newport is yours on the
exempt document
no okay
members during the debate
uh if you need to ask questions
about the exempt as they crop up please
advise me prior to you mentioning that
councillor newport would you like to
bring your question please
oh
thank you madam chairman um
just in
a
reference to the savings or projected
savings to be made
um is it possible to tell us how
these savings will be reported on please
thank you councilman
are there any other questions
counselor wilkinson
do you have a question
thank you chad
i think we'll have to hold it sorry
thank you chairman and uh thank you to
the leader for the presentation report
and i'd echo what uh i said at the
review committee so thanks to all the
officers and all the uh members who are
involved in preparing this report
because it would have taken an awful lot
of time
i wholeheartedly support the comments
that the leader has made um regarding
not just report but also uh councillor
wilson's um
leadership of the review committee which
was outstanding um i have absolutely no
hesitation whatsoever and supporting
this and i would encourage all members
to do so i think it's a positive move
for the council i can't see anything any
negatives in it whatsoever and and i
would
urge all members to please support this
thank you thank you councillor
councillor wilton are you able to answer
those uh
councillor newport's question
ah
thank you angela hutchins
thank you chair
um councillor newport the reporting of
the savings will initially come through
the program management of the
transformation unit if i can direct you
to paragraph five of the review
committee report on page 3.8
uh it details the fact that the
reporting will also then go through each
council's individual corporate
governance
quarterly update to the executive
and in advance of those meetings
presented to the review committee for
questions to be asked for performance to
be scrutinized
sorry
i take it that answers your question
counselor nicole
thank you
okay
members we have 13 recommendations set
out at paragraph 9.1 on pages 4.7
4.8 of the report
and i will read them as follows
to agree the strategic partnership
between rochford district council and
brentwood borough council
and that jonathan stephenson is the
joint executive for both councils with
effect from the 1st of february 2022
to appoint jonathan stevenson as the
council's head of paid services with
effect from the first of february
twenty twenty two
to approve the heads of terms the heads
of terms set out in appendix
a item four that the joint chief
executive and the monitoring officer of
each council be given delegated
authority in consultation with the
leader of each council to enter into a
memorandum of understanding
and an s 113 agreement
to give effect to the partnership
item five
that the joint chief executive be given
delegated authority to undertake a
restructure of tiers 2 and 3
of the councils in consultation with the
leader of each
council item six
that the designated head of paid
services is the proper officer under
s
2 7 0
0 3 of the local government act 1972
item seven
that the maximum of three hundred
thousand pound as set out in paragraph
6.7 of this report
be allocated from general reserves to
fund the additional program resource for
the transformation unit
item eight
that the monitoring officer be given
delegated authority
in consultation with the portfolio
holder for governance
to make any required changes to the
constitution
to give effect to the recommendations in
this report
item nine
that the memorandum of understanding and
the s-113 agreement makes provision for
robust exit agreement arrangements
and a member-led conflict resolution
process
item 10
that the s113 agreement comes to the
review committee for scrutiny before it
is executed
item 11. that the feedback from
residents as to the impact of the
partnership on services is regularly
sought and reported upon
item 12 that there be an early review of
technology in phase two of the
transformation program
to identify threats and or opportunities
item 13 that the memorandum of
understanding
and or other document that underpins the
strategic partnership
makes clear that whilst the division of
the savings achieved as part of the
transformation process is to be agreed
between two councils
that the starting point for that
discussion should be fifty-fifty
members are you happy to vote for the 13
recommendations on block
ok thank you
can those in favor please raise their
hands right up and keep them up while
officers count them and don't lower them
until i ask you to do so
thank you members please close your hand
that vote is unanimous and is carried
thank you
thank you members
that concludes the item of business i
will now turn to item 5 on the agenda
thank you just i think he's just gonna
bring
thank you madam chairman
[Music]
hello
my apologies i should have declared an
at non-pecuniary interest on item five
as i'm a hackney taxi driver thank you
councillor carter
councillor carter if i may uh this is
about the policy around the gambling act
not hackney carriages
so do you wish to withdraw that
counselor
bro
thank you chairman um in fairness to
councillor carter on the evening of the
licensing meeting there was an item
regarding tactical carriage in respect
of hackney courage and i think that he's
got confused that both of them have been
brought forward to council when they
haven't so just thank you council kai
for paul
thank you for that clarification
i will now invite councillor arthur
williams chairman of the licensing and
appeals committee to introduce the
report
thank you chairman
members as a council we're obliged to
have a licensing policy in place
we are asked to consider the state the
statement of licensing policy
gambling act 2005
for
2022-2025
following the statutory consultation
this matter was discussed and reviewed
by the licensing and appeals committee
on 18th of january
as chairman of this committee unable to
report that it was unanimous decision by
the committee to recommend to the
council that this recommendation be
approved this evening
if there are any questions i'm sure the
officers or the relevant portfolio
holder will be able to answer these
thank you members
councillor smith
thank you chairman i'd just like to
demonstrate that i have read the report
and comment on the fact that the page
numbering on page 5.8 doesn't actually
match the contents of the report thank
you
that is noted thank you councillor smith
are there any members that wish to ask
any questions
okay members we'll move to the vote then
those in favor
please raise your hand
thank you members please lower your hand
that motion is unanimous and carried
thank you
members just before i close the meeting
i would just like to say that there is
a condolence book outside for those
people that haven't managed to
sign it and would like to
and i will now close the meeting at
2003 thank you members
you